foreign
diagnosis about four and a half years
ago how do I live an emotionally healthy
life for my wife and our five children
I've made a change recently to something
that specializes in mental health and I
see a counselor on a weekly basis
husband to husband I'm proud of you
[Music]
live
and tonight what's up this is John with
the Dr John deloney's show
man I'm so glad that you're with us this
is not a show
where I sing because I'm terrible at
that
um but this is a show where I walk
alongside you on the greatest mental
health and marriage and parenting
podcast ever and we figure out what's
the next right thing for you to do
um the world's gotten sideways on us and
it has become a mess and that's what
we're here for here to walk alongside
you if you want to be on the show give
me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 please don't forget to
remember just to hit the Subscribe
button if you're watching Youtube just
click it click it and if you are
listening on podcasts just subscribe
such a gift
to me yeah self-serving of course but
more importantly it puts the show in the
hands of other people it puts it in the
algorithms in the smoke and mirrors or
whatever is going on in the internets
and and it shows up on more people's
feeds the more uh reviews the positive
reviews and the more subscriptions so
thank you so much so much so much it's a
way to support the show and other people
without having to buy anything man and
good grief y'all getting beat to death
with buying things so thank you so much
for somebody out here in the crowd just
bought some books so thank you so much
man
um all right let's roll off and talk to
Grant in Spokane Washington what's up
Grant
I am doing uh I'm doing well thanks for
having me on your show I'm looking
forward to getting some feedback all
right let's figure it out man what's up
all right I've been diagnosed with a
bipolar diagnosis about four and a half
years ago okay initially it was bipolar
type two and then more recently it's
been bipolar type one my question is how
do I live an emotionally healthy life
for my wife and our five children
hmm
uh what what
did you have a significant manic episode
that had them re-diagnose you
um they just uh they they thought that I
had more of a depressive episodes okay
that were more affecting my life but
according to the diagnosis you need to
have a manic episode for more than five
consecutive days and typically my my
diagna or my my high phases last seven
to ten days
okay
um what what
um
what have you done to manage care over
the last four and a half years
have you kept yourself well medication
that wasn't working effectively okay I
think I think I was just I was too loyal
to her to a health system that that
wasn't specialized in mental health just
kind of general practitioner here in
Spokane yeah and um yeah I've made a
change recently to something that
specializes in mental health and I see a
counselor on a weekly basis and I see my
my psychiatrist probably I've been with
them about 90 days and I've seen her
probably half a dozen times in those 90
days Wow have you seen a uptick in your
uh mood and stabilization
feeling better yes yeah I think so good
deal man that's excellent hey can I just
tell you this just guide a guy uh
husband to husband I'm proud of you
thanks good for you and there's days
that um you feel good and you don't want
to take your meds because you feel like
I'm good man and you take them anyway
and I'm proud of you
it's hard okay
yep I'm proud of you all right so how do
you be a good partner to wife five kids
what's precipitated this
did something happen did you do
something what like why why today
my wife and I we've been separated about
11 months
um my my oldest daughter she's gonna
turn 13 in about two weeks okay and she
and I are not on a talking terms
I've uh I've traumatized her and I've
said terrible things through an active
and atrocious ways when I've been
unstable and she just doesn't want me to
be in her life at all okay and uh our
marriage is
man our marriage is hanging on barely
um
sounds like it's over brother
like y'all have been separated for
almost a year now it sounds like it's
over is this you not
holding is this not you not
acknowledging reality or is your is your
wife saying no we're still working
through this
when I called when I called the Dave
Ramsey Show I talked to Ken Coleman and
George Campbell they said a number one
protect the kids and a number one and a
this fight to save the marriage and
fighting to save the marriage looks like
taking care of my mental health making
my appointments taking my meds
and then number two fighting to save the
marriage is call before I come over and
create positive memories and work on
chores with the kids and sharing stuff
like I notice these chores which one is
more higher priority my spouse hold on
so I want to I want to reframe that a
little bit okay
taking your meds
getting counseling
moving your body and exercising and
putting good food into your body like
getting some sleep
that isn't to save your marriage that's
for you to be well and whole
and when you get well in whole
and you get stabilized
and you have some coping mechanisms for
when your body starts to drag you
underwater which you've experienced and
when your body duct tapes you to a
rocket ship which you've experienced
when you get some coping strategies and
some behavior management strategies on
on those during those seasons
then you are in a place
to begin to work on your marriage
and it sounds like semantics but it's a
huge difference here's why if your
marriage is over
if your wife has all but left you which
it sounds like she has
you still need to take your meds and
work on having a good life you got five
kids that need their dad okay you
deserve a life of peace and you haven't
had that in a long long time
right
that would be correct okay
so our Focus right now is getting Grant
well and healthy
and that will allow you to focus on the
kids that will allow you to
focus on your marriage
and
um let me try to say this in a right way
that's kind
um
when's the
this is a I don't want to paint everyone
with bipolar in this in this and with
one broad stroke okay but
um here is something I've seen with the
limited number of folks I've worked with
they are very very very smart
lightning smart and on up Seasons they
are able to their computational power is
so much faster and so much more vast
than than a normal guy like me
and they're able to see solutions to
problems sometimes it don't even exist
yet
but they create solutions to situations
and that's often good unless those
problems are relational
and then what you end up doing is coming
up with the ways you're going to save
your marriage and you forget to ask your
wife
and then you start doubling down on a
bunch of activities and actions and they
don't work because it's not part of what
your wife needs to be whole in this
marriage and then it's agonizing and
frustrating and then your body starts
flipping switches on you
am I on the right path
I'm I'm trying to keep up with you okay
so when's the last time you sat down
with your wife and said what's the
status of our marriage
um I think at the beginning of October
we we pushed pause on marriage
counseling for three months and
we've been seeing a marriage counselor
on a weekly basis for 90 days or so okay
why why who who pushed pause and why
I think financially we
financially we'd come to the end of the
financial resources okay
um
and just not seeing any progress or
change or difference I I can't point to
one thing and say this is different than
the last 90 days okay
has she filed for divorce yet she filed
for illegal separation yet we've talked
about illegal separation okay
let's go to your kids you're a 13 year
old right now is right
okay
she's right
you scared the hell out of her
you said some tough stuff
and for a 13 year old now you're what
you're doing my brothers you're playing
a long game
okay the dad's well dad's gonna take his
medication dad's going to not grovel and
try to earn your love back
but your dad's just gonna keep showing
up and keep showing up because I love
you and if she says I don't want you in
my presence you're gonna say cool I love
you here's what we want we're going to
play a game it's a long game that's 10
years from now
so at 23 here's what I want her to have
a handwritten letter from her dad every
two weeks for 10 years
okay telling her how she's doing how
proud of her you are
make the letter about her make her the
hero of the letter not about Dad this is
about her how much you love her
how proud of what a beautiful young
woman she is what a gritty brilliant
young woman she is
um
I want her to have a firm understanding
about how loved she is
and at the same time I want to respect
her autonomy that she gets to choose to
not be terrified and scared again for a
while
it's both and okay
is that fair
I think that's fair okay what about your
other kids
um our 11 year old doesn't live at home
anymore
um
she she and my wife don't have the best
relationship
and then we have an eight-year-old a
six-year-old and a three-year-old boy so
we had four daughters of another son
okay
went to younger three they still want me
to know like this so appreciate me
coming by and they felt like it me being
involved in their life
um
my my 11 year old
isn't Hospitality isn't as prickly as my
13 year old okay but I I think doing the
letter thing if I can do it for one of
them I could probably do it for each one
of them and that probably would be
healthy
for them to look back on the past yep I
know I would have appreciated it from my
dad yeah and here's a cool thing about
um
foreign go have a visit with your three
kids that want to hang out with you you
go through a visit with those three and
you'll have a great time
they remember the feelings
but they don't always remember exactly
what Dad said
and if you say something dumb over the
next few years which if you're a parent
you for sure will I know I will
um our bodies have a way of remembering
the negative stuff more than the
positive stuff and
ex-spouses have a
more likely to bring up well your dad
said that right negative stuff
the beauty of having a letter is they
can read it over and over and over again
it crystallizes in their mind how
valuable and beautiful and wonderful and
gritty and smart they are so says
they're dead you see what I'm saying
hey yes sir
um
your daughter is living with your aunt
why isn't she why aren't any of these
kids living with you have you had your
kids removed
have they been taken from you
I know that we've had uh CPS cases over
the last probably
uh five years and they were because of
action that I had
neglect that probably would be able to
be using the figure planted at me what'd
you do
I need you to talk directly into the
phone too it's starting to fade a little
bit uh what happened I
I let a two-year-old go out and you know
winter scene with snow on the ground and
all she had was a diaper on I did
realize that she'd gone out of the house
the neighbor found her brought her back
okay what else
um my kid's reporting to the nurse at
school if they didn't feel safe at home
okay
were you violent with them
probably
I don't remember it's I don't remember
specific
instances of being violent towards them
I did there was a time when I took a
door off of the changes and showed
violence that way towards our house and
I I was out of control okay
so here's what it sounds like the
greatest gift you can give your kids
right now is for you to be well
okay and this is hard to hear but you're
doing the right things right now
you're gonna have to keep working real
real hard and there's going to be a
there's going to be it's just going to
take time
uh smashing a door off its hinges in
your house with four little kids or five
little kids is trauma that's what that
is and you know that I'm not gonna kick
you while you're down
um you can't put that door back on the
hinges and you can't sweep up all the
pieces of the door that are on the floor
and rebuild it and say hey it's all good
what you have to do over a long period
of time is get yourself stable and get
yourself well and you're doing the right
things you got a full-time psychiatrist
you got a full-time therapist you're
doing the work
do the work for Grant
because Grant deserves to be whole
and then do it for those kids
it sounds to me my brother like your
marriage is over and I think it's time
for some very concrete conversations
with your wife are you done
is this entity over you will always be
in relationship with her because you'll
share five kids
always is this done because you're
spending a lot of energy trying to keep
together a Unity that might be over
okay let's get some very clear answers
here
and let's not ever stop taking our meds
let's not ever hop out of counseling
okay and let's work a long game to get
ourselves well in whole so that we are
safe around our kids not so we show them
and trick them so that we become safe in
their presence
your kids have a pretty uncanny knack
for feeling it
glassy-eyed dad versus oh Dad sees me
there he is
that's one two three four years down the
road let's work towards that my brother
okay
thanks for being brave thanks for trying
to turn the sucker around you're worth
it they're worth it keep fighting my man
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead
take a deep breath because Churchill has
your back check them out at
churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org equal housinglender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and are not available in
all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to
Caitlyn and where's she at Salt Lake
City what's up Caitlin how we doing
hi Dr John how's it going good what's up
good
um
nothing much just hanging out
nothing much
yep so what's up how can I help let's
fix it yes I had a question for you so
how do my husband I set boundaries with
our in-laws regarding disciplining our
children
oh sweet are they trying to spank your
kids or yell at your kids or something
[Laughter]
I'm just kidding yeah it's too simple
um
oh can I just be honest with you I wish
this was a really complex answer and
it's not
you and your husband make very clear
what you will or will not tolerate when
it comes to your kids and then you give
other adults the opportunity to choose
whether they want to see their grandkids
or not it's that simple
yeah and if another adult wants to hit
my kid
then that adult does not ever get to be
in the presence of my child ever again
and that's a choice they've made not me
if another adult wants to yell at my kid
or tell racist jokes around my kid or
swear on my kid
not great good for you you will never
see my child again because that's my job
and you hear my voice like I don't give
a crap Who You Are
you know what I mean like I I absolutely
don't care
yeah and I've had to have not uh like
those are I'm being extreme I'm trying
to sound all tough I'm not I'm kind of a
wimp but
um I'm trying to sound tough but I've
had to have conversations with a lot of
people in my life that I love and say
hey hey
you will not talk that way in front of
my kid yeah and
very clearly that's not gonna happen and
I've had everybody respect it but one or
two people and those people don't get to
see my kid anymore and I don't care I
don't care right yeah because they're
grown-ups let me grown-up choices tell
your jokes do your thing I don't care
it's not gonna see my kids see see I
mean I hope you're getting my sentiment
I I it
I don't owe you anything when it comes
to my children
I agree okay so what are you
experiencing I'm talking all over you
clearly this is like a like a button for
me like what are you what are you
working through
so I guess it's not so much that we have
decided that we want to talk to our
family about how we think is appropriate
to
talk to our children like I would just
rather
to not do anything at all personally
um
but
it's hot it's really hard for my husband
to talk to his family because they're
not oh
like they're just not
the nicest oh your husband's poor
husband I kind of want to hug him
I here's the deal I don't care and I
don't want to talk bad about your
husband if he was on the phone
I would be harder on him it's his
parents get over it suck it up tell him
yeah like you're a grown man he went and
got married and had kids that's he made
that choice
sister don't have to put your kids in
that situation if your husband's too
much of a coward to talk to his family
about how they're treating his children
then you might have to step in and say
well then my kids aren't going
yeah
does that make sense what what are they
doing
now I just know I've been talking crap
you're gonna be like well they throw
cotton balls at him when they get mad
like no what are they doing and it's not
like every time oh that's a that's a
that's abuse apologizer I don't care if
it's that every time just one time if
you hit my kid with an iron Rod one time
that's enough it doesn't have to be
every time it was just no and it's not
it's not hitting
um but like
I'm trying to think so she's she's one
she's turning two soon so she's just
barely gotten into like the throwing
tantrum phase where she freaks out you
know
um and like
he'll make almost like
not dog noises at her but like
it's a sound that you would make to
correct a dog if they were doing
something that wasn't okay right you're
getting like ah it's getting under my
skin I guess like it's like crawling on
me because I know here's it I know
exactly what it is crazy too that's that
oh my gosh you know what that is
that's that's a
that is power
yes I have 100 million over you pet
and you know what one-year-olds do
they just get sensory overload a temper
tantrum by a one-year-old is not a
character flaw
it's not a defect they're they're one
now there's proper ways to deal it as a
parent right
and yeah hey
that is not the way to handle it no I
mean she's she's a person you know so
here's the deal
somebody has to stop and say hey hey hey
hey
you're not going to treat my child like
a dog
in that in that tone of voice
yeah I'm gonna pick up my kid
nobody's gonna whistle and here's here
is my uh
I don't know how to I don't know how to
say this without saying oh woo-woo kids
are radar systems for tension
and if they get put in the position of
somebody that thinks they're a pet
or that holds that sort of relational
hierarchy with them I am better than you
I'm superior to you I've got bigger
muscles than you here's a little lump of
human that will do whatever I say
kids feel that
and seven-year-olds don't want to go
visit granddad
yeah 13 year olds
run away from granddad
one-year-olds just light up like a
Christmas tree because that's all they
know how to do
right and so it wouldn't surprise me at
all if a kid who's had to travel to
granddad's house who's exhausted mom and
dad are tense because they're going to
in-laws house and the kids absorbing
that tension you'll show up there and
then this
yeah yeah shows up yeah that kid's gonna
have a temper tantrum you know why
that's exactly how he was made good for
him yeah he's letting you his mom know
not safe not safe not safe and then he
gets treated with a dog whistle then do
that just like straight pisses me off
and they like I'm I'm sitting here
getting fired up for you it's not even
my kid
oh trust me we both
do I just
that that is an in the moment correction
and I will pack up my stuff and go home
I just I just don't care you know what
I'm gonna have on the way home more fun
yeah right I'm gonna eat at Arby's and
Taco Bell and just get the Rockets all
the way home love my life don't care
yeah
why won't your husband talk to his
parents
too because Mom can step in and say
something too they're divorced oh okay
that's cute okay
well I wonder I wonder if I wonder if
she liked being talked to that way her
during her marriage
but I think a lot of it is because he
was treated the same way so very
like
degraded like even as an adult like
if he does something his dad thinks is
weird or dumb or something he'll be like
why are you such an idiot you know
like he just
he just
Berets him sometimes honestly and it it
drives me crazy of course because you
love this man you know he's not an idiot
he does dumb things because he's human
but he's not an idiot and you don't want
anybody talking to your husband that way
I don't care who you are exactly
so
I think for him
like the confidence to stand up to his
dad because he knows he knows fully well
but when he does he's gonna get crap
from him that he's an idiot and he
doesn't know how to pair a kid right and
bang-up job you did Dad way to go crush
the crush the marriage too way to go Dad
yeah yeah wait knock it knocked it out
of the park dude way to go yeah right so
so when my dad tells me about parenting
I have to listen because I look at the
fruit of his three kids he did a good
job
yeah right and so even when I don't want
to hear it I do I do owe him that
respect because uh it's played out
right
um your husband doesn't have that same
luxury
it's and here's the deal if he refuses
or can't or won't it's won't he can if
he won't
then at some point you say me and my
baby are not going to visit him anymore
and if he your husband wimps out and
tells his dad if she don't want to come
see you anymore
she doesn't like the way you talk to the
baby
um and again I hope you can see how
cowardly that would sound but that's
probably how the conversation would go
um and he calls you you might have to
tell him
I'm tired he called my husband an idiot
because he's not he's a good man I'm
tired of you talking down to me I'm a
good wife I'm a good mom tired of you
whistling in our kid
like he's some kind of like he's a cow
out in the pasture I'm not doing it
anymore
until you treat me and my family with
dignity or respect we're out
yeah so you think it's a it's a
correction when it's happening
absolutely because that's a power
Dynamic and here's how that will
probably end because nobody stands up to
a bully like that
it will probably end with y'all packing
your crap and leaving
because I don't just based on what you
told me he ain't going back down
he's gonna stand his ground
yeah so that's what we do around here
it's hard to know because
oh I listen I know this guy you know why
because I grew up with this guy
I know this guy and that's why I got
such a visceral response to him dude I
moved here from West Texas like I just I
could feel it man
I can feel it
yeah it's just an arrogance that the
world bends to me
I don't care if it's a business deal I
don't care if it's a home I don't care
if it's your kid you bow before me
I don't care if it's a one-year-old that
just misses mama is tired
good grief whistling at a one-year-old
unbelievable
um I do think your husband needs to suck
it up and have a hard conversation
okay okay
um and it won't end well
and he's probably going to look at you
and say this is your fault because he
doesn't understand what relationship is
because he's never seen it
okay
yeah I mean well we're we're pretty on
the same page I mean we're
probably the complete opposite from both
of our families so good for you hey
y'all are creating something new good
for you
why do you even go why be in this dude's
presence
foreign
fantasy
this is the way these are supposed to go
the picture I had when I had a kid was
that he was going to have a great
grandparents and we're gonna have
holidays we're going to look that look
like this we're gonna Christmas doesn't
look like this
and we're gonna have hunting trips and
fishing trips and shopping trips and
you're the adults in your life have
chosen that that's not going to be a
reality
and so as soon as you're able to you'll
need to create a new reality based on
the data in front of you
based on the relationships that are in
front of you
not based on how you wish it was because
wish it was isn't happening right now
and
if he's got if your father-in-law has
one iota of
reflective ability
hopefully he would ask at some point hey
why do y'all
what do you mean you're not coming for
Thanksgiving
Dad we're just going to do it on our own
this year but I'll come down and visit
you no thank you we're going on a trip
we're gonna go to we're going to go
somewhere on our own
we're gonna start our own family
traditions
you don't like me you don't want to see
me we're tired of you calling me an
idiot I'm done with it Dad I put up with
it my whole life and I'm done with it
and I got my own son now my own daughter
now and we're not doing this again
stops with me
that's gangster right there you know
what that is that's family tree changing
it's generational it's Legacy
that's it no more
hang on the line I'ma send you a copy of
on your past change your future you and
your husband can read it together
there's not a chapter on how to have
grown up hard conversations but there is
a chapter on owning reality this is what
is
then there's a whole back half the book
on
here's what we're gonna do now
good for you for loving that kid
no more people talking your child like
they're a pet good grief we'll be right
back
hey it's Dr John deloney here look
people are always saying the holidays
are the most wonderful time of the year
right for some of us the holidays are
great some of us the holidays are not
great but for all of us the holidays are
Mayhem you're probably traveling all
over the place talking to family members
you didn't even ask for by the way
shopping trying to deal with all the
parties and no one will turn off the
Christmas music you know who you are but
inside the chaos you still have a choice
the choice to take care of yourself and
the best way to navigate the chaos of
the holidays is to make sure you are
well and being well starts with a good
night's sleep and I found that good
sleep starts with a great mattress and
that's why my family sleeps on dream
Cloud dream Cloud mattresses combination
of gel memory foam and coil technology
keeps you comfortable all night and
right now dream cloud is running their
biggest offer ever exclusively for our
listeners 599 dollars in accessories
plus an additional 250 dollar discount
that's 849 dollars in accessories and
savings visit dreamcloudsleep.com
deloney or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code deloni to get your new
mattress and start getting the rest your
body needs
all right we are back and I have a
better attitude now after the last call
oh that got under my skin all right
let's go to Susan in Phoenix what's up
Susan
hi Dr Ron uh it's great to speak to you
you too what's up
well I'm a co-owner of a small business
and one of my roles at the company is to
manage HR in the office so you know
hiring firing how small issues uh we
have about 10 people at any given time
so it's pretty small
HR in an office of 10 people is like
managing brothers and sisters and
cousins exactly and there's always a
couple of weird cousins oh geez good for
you congratulations yeah yeah so sorry
yeah what's up no worries um so I've
noticed kind of an increase in mental
health issues that have Arisen probably
since covid but frankly just generally
speaking I think the world is kind of
creating a lot more mental health issues
in people
so my broad question is just in my role
how do I show empathy and compassion for
individual struggles while still getting
work done in the office and getting
productivity out of my staff so you know
people are struggling with depression
they're they have you know divorce
issues that I've been encountering
marital problems uh crippling anxiety
you know these are all things that are
really impacting you know their
productivity so
um do you have any suggestions and I can
get into specifics if that would help
um let me make some broad suggestions
and then come back if I don't answer
your question okay okay and I'm having
this conversation all over the country
I've talked to Business Leaders all over
the United States on how to create these
systems and their businesses and here's
a couple of operating principles for how
to do this okay so first and foremost
good for you for being a a business
owner that cares good grief thank you
thank you thank you treating your
customers like widgets
um or like robots for you to make more
money thank you for being somebody who
sees people as humans that's awesome
um so yes there is an influx there's
just a kind of a big reveal and it
happened over night here in the country
we're all kind of figuring out what to
do with it everybody's talking about
mental health stuff right yeah and it's
suddenly overnight become okay to tell
your boss I'm depressed or I've been
I've been diagnosed with OCD or
something like that
there's also been
a what I would say not healthy
over sharing that has happened and I
think it's it's chat rooms or something
Have bled over into real life
where people are announcing in staff
meeting I cheated on my wife and now
she's left me and it's like whoa whoa
whoa whoa dude we we make boxes like
that's between you and your therapist
and you and your pastor or whoever you
and your friends
um and so there's been this weird
culture of over sharing that's emerged
overnight and here's the deal
it's a weird moment in history where
somebody can drop that kind of grenade
and if you say the wrong thing you're
the bad guy right like if you stumble
over like well uh
you're evil because you didn't fill in
the blank right you didn't accept me or
you judged me or now I'm more anxious or
whatever right yeah
so
um here's I'll give you three three
things that I would recommend
um you you do to create a culture of
both mental health and hey we still have
a business to run here okay
it's it's compassionate but it's also we
got stuff we got to do okay the first
one is this is about relationships with
appropriate distance
and you're gonna let your people know
hey we are a safe place if you're
struggling let us know and we will
support you the best we can here's what
support means
I do not want to know your diagnosis
unless it's coming from a medical doctor
and you need an ADA uh accommodation for
your workplace
um I don't want you like don't ever come
in and say I've never told anybody this
but I'll stop somebody and say whoa whoa
whoa I shouldn't be the first person you
tell I don't even know what you're about
to say but it shouldn't be me I don't
know you that well I'm your boss or
you might tell me something that as your
supervisor I have to act on
okay if somebody comes in and says hey
I'm really struggling with anxiety when
I get anxious I steal stuff
well you can't work here if you're
stealing from us
and the response isn't I've got anxiety
though no you can't steal it's both and
okay so I tell people this is a safe
place here's what that looks like hey
I've been struggling a lot I'm seeing a
counselor can I knock off at four once a
week Absolutely I'll even pay you for
that hour
that's what relationship with
appropriate distance looks like hey
everybody I've got a I've posted a list
of 10 counselors in this local area and
I posted in the break room and I've got
to deal with him if you tell them you
work at our place I'm going to pick up
25 or half the tab so your visit will be
50 bucks go in there you don't even have
to let me know they'll just bill me
directly
okay okay that's way like you are
letting them know you care about them
here's a resource
but I don't know what to do when you
tell me you have major depressive
disorder and you can't come to work but
you still need me to pay you I don't I
don't know I don't I'm not trained to
deal with that I'm not trained to deal
with your suicide response that's why
I'm gonna if you tell me you're suicidal
I'm calling 9-1-1 every single time
because that's not my core competency
I'm not trained in that okay
okay and you're providing them resources
to the professionals that can get them
the help they really need right right
the second thing is this
um and this isn't popular but this is
reality
mental health challenges in the
workplace are a context not an excuse
okay
yeah I am a guy who has suffered
profoundly from anxiety in the past I
don't struggle at all with it anymore
not even a little bit but in the past it
it laid me low
I had two responsibilities there one I
had to get my job done that my boss was
paying me to do
and I had to do the work on my own to go
get well
and in my particular office place I let
people know a few people privately hey
I've got to knock off to go see a
counselor is that cool absolutely that's
great
hey I'm not gonna be able to come to
this event tomorrow night because it's
me and my wife go to marriage counseling
and I'm gonna have to miss it great
or hey I've got to move my counseling
appointment because I've got this really
important work thing and I can't miss it
okay or my wife and I took a 70 000
household income pay cut to go from me
running a entire University to me us
moving to another city and me taking a
assignment with a smaller with several
hundred students instead of several
thousand students so that for the next
several years I could get myself well
that was on me not on the not on the
other Institution
does that make sense yeah so it's a
context not an excuse if if the job
comes second to
the the it ends up dishonoring the
person doubt that has hired you guys for
help
for your service it's a dishonoring to
them if the job doesn't get done and
someone can say hey I just woke up this
morning with lots of anxiety I'm just
not coming in today
that's not acceptable response yeah
that's what's happened right
historically okay so they can wake up
and have anxiety and if you have a
business that allows them to come in
late great sometimes people are like
Frontline customers sir I need someone
to unlock the door
and you can't call me 15 minutes before
work starts and say I've got anxiety
this morning and so I'm not going to be
there
um that's that's unethical it's it's not
Integris okay it might be that I gotta
get myself to to the office and open the
door and I'm gonna call some people to
come in and cover my shift for me
because I can't I gotta go and I've been
there before
I gotta get out of here but I still had
to go open the door
and maybe it's creating a phone tree so
that if somebody wakes up and they are
really struggling and you've met with
them and you've got a note from their
therapist or from the Ada office or
whatever
that you've got a phone tree that that
person can reach out and call but it's
going to be their responsibility to make
that call
does that make sense
yeah yeah it does it's it's it's a both
end
um you have to
take care of business you can't just not
show up to work or you can't work here
okay right um here's the third one you
have to model this
you have to model it that means you have
to be open about your what you are
experiencing in your personal challenges
with resp with
um appropriate boundaries
okay meaning that I'm supposed to tell
them uh what's going on with other
people or no no no no never ever do that
myself I'm saying here if you if you are
struggling with something if you get
tired if you get exhausted you get
burned out you're going to marriage
counseling that during a staff meeting
you let everybody know hey I'm knocking
off it on Tuesday because I'm gonna go
I'm seeing a professional to work
through some stuff
um you are modeling oh that's okay
Andy you're also modeling
I'm not telling you that I've got
depression I'm not telling you that my
husband cheated on me we're going to
marriage couns am I telling you any of
the goal details I'm just telling you
that I'm going to take care of myself
and then later on you point back to the
way you did it as the model so when
someone says okay I'm struggling to say
stop remember when I did it I let y'all
know I'm going to get help and Care
what's your what Your diagnosis is
between you and your therapist between
you and your doctor
right does that make sense and and you
got to come to work you got to be at
work
so so for people that aren't coming into
work because that's kind of one of the
issues with the around anxiety
um do you do you allow them to work
remotely my fear is that they're not
going to work remotely or do you you
know let them take the time off but then
it impacts other people that have to
take over their workload you know what I
mean at some point it's just not going
to work out but up until then what how
do you how do I handle that sort of a
situation I don't have any problem and
this isn't popular with large
corporations when you when you get super
big it becomes very unwieldy and so
that's where you get these big blanket
policies that we don't do this or we do
this when you have a staff of 10
um I like it how my boss Dave Ramsey did
it once he stood up and said we are
growing company size and there's a
particular leader who's got a particular
situation
and I'm the boss and so here's how I'm
helping him out
here's how I'm helping her out and it
it was a one-off situation and there's
been multiple one-offs here at where I
work at Ramsey Solutions every every
Leader's got the upper the ability to do
some one-offs with their people but
here's the catch for a limited time
so it might be someone come in and say I
am double over with anxiety I'm really
struggling I just can't breathe I need
some time and you might be able to say I
can do two weeks
for two weeks someone else is going to
pick up your shift you are going to have
to come up in that two weeks with
are you able to work here to get your
job done do you have a workable solution
we are a work in the office company and
so we are not ever going to transition
to fully remote and so or we are slowly
moving towards remote we're going to
practice it and we're going to let you
be the guinea pig right but I don't have
any problem with one-offs what I don't
like about one-offs is when they become
very secret hey don't tell anybody but
I'm gonna let you do I wouldn't do it
like that
because it never stay secret and then it
looks it can be discriminatory you let
that person do it you let it's better
just to open it up to the floor
so and so let said I could share with
y'all that she's really struggling or
he's really struggling and so for the
next two weeks they're not gonna be here
does it means you're gonna have to pick
up a little extra I mean you have to
pick a little extra and then within two
weeks we're gonna have a resolution on
how this how what happens next
okay but it's got It's Time limited
right and it might be you need to reach
out I wouldn't even get in the business
of calling the therapist I I take that
back but it's time limiting and at some
point you have to sit down and say hey
um you're unable to complete the core
tasks of this job
The Bona Fide occupational requirements
of this position right
and this is a hard hard conversation and
maybe I think the workable I think the
workable solution idea is a good one
um because you know one thought I had
was well you give them a a month to not
do that anymore but then if there's no
solution attached to it it'll just
they'll just Resort back to doing it
when they've returned so right and and I
want people I want people to struggle
with is this anxiety or is this
exhaustion
am I is my body signing the alarms that
I need to go get help or I'm just
annoyed this morning I don't feel like
going in because all of us have those
days all of us do and I remember how
hard it was when I was trying to relearn
what my body was trying to tell me and
my signals were all jumbled up because I
ignored them for so long and I
wallpapered over them with busyness and
work and my crushing workout plan all
these different addictions I had over it
and ultimately I had to learn okay this
is my body saying things are not as they
should be this is anxiety this is what
this feels like
this is me being really exhausted this
is me having a large pizza in half a two
liter bottle of coke all by myself
this is all right fill in the blank fill
in the blank fill in the blank so I do
get it takes some time to parse that
apart
um and I want people to struggle with
that I think that's the path to healing
for all of us
the challenge is as an employer is you
can't do other people's healing for them
they've got to be invested in it
themselves again thank you for being
somebody who cares Susan
um try these out relationships but
appropriate distance context not an
excuse context but not an excuse and
model it give those a shot and then to
holler back at me if I can help moving
forward thank you so much for the call
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
we are back and we're gonna end the show
Full Circle Kelly just brought these in
because this is your favorite I think
this is how we're opening battle bands
next year
I hundred percent am on board with that
I think it would I think it would slay I
think so
from the great James Hetfield in gang
songs by Metallica it's called inner
Sandman
and these lyrics will brighten your day
[Music]
say your prayers little one and don't
forget my son to include everyone
I tuck you in warm within and keep you
free from sin till the Sandman comes
sleep with one eye open gripping your
pillow tight
exit light
enter night and take my hand off to
Never Never Land
something's wrong shut the light heavy
thoughts tonight
and they aren't of Snow White
I don't ever think of Snow White I don't
know what to tell you everybody hey
we'll see you soon we love you take care
[Music]